so this is going to be a quick video on
how to use the dashboard to understand
what's going on with the results of your
meta genomic data analysis so we're on
the T by info platform we kind of
process this data either with chyme
chime or with data2 pipelines and here
we have kind of the basic composition of
our data
so we can select here level of taxonomy
for example we can go higher on the
level of taxonomy or we could go lower
on the level of taxonomy
remember that a lot of these are not
going to be mapped well so for example
you can see that the majority of the
data at the species level is ambiguous
so if we kind of look at this it tells
us right away that maybe that's not a
very good way to look at that actually I
see also other okay there we go so a lot
of this tax is not going to be mapped so
you can remove that simply by clicking
on that particular taxa
so here now you can hover over and you
can see what are these taxa and a lot of
times these are unidentified species and
uncultured right you can see there's a
lot of issues at this lower level so
let's go to the phylum level
so here it's very clear the majority of
them are annotated so we can remove the
other and we can see that there's some
variation
so let's say we kind of spot visually
that there's a difference between these
two samples let's take a look for
example
at something like
uh let well let's just go through for
example if you double click
you will only get that particular taxes
so here we can go through and see the
differences and it looks like there
might be some differences between the
two groups so here we have the control
and here we have the psoriasis
so let's go and maybe take a look at
another one for example chloroflexi is
only present in psoriasis but only in
two samples so it's not a lot of
confidence that this is actually
significant right
cyanobacteria cyanobacteria seems to be
present abundant both in control and
psoriasis
here again only one sample
so we can kind of go through now a lot
of times that's the limitation of again
this taxonomic level it doesn't provide
us with a very good resolution and a lot
of it seems to be kind of all over the
place and the main reason for that is
because there's so many actual bacteria
that fall under these phylum
so let's go
let's go into the order
here again we're kind of visually it
might be a little bit confusing so we
might want to take a look at some of
these examples
um maybe for example this one is only
present in controls
okay and so just by exploring our data
we can start identifying some Trends and
these Trends could be very useful
because we can start asking specific
questions about these types of bacteria
and we can also manually find some of
them
that are very interesting so
here for example
okay here we have some bacteria that's
maybe more abundant in the control
or this bacteria is more abundant maybe
in the psoriasis
so that's how you can navigate this now
you in addition to this you have here
some kind of a
global comparison between the different
groups and a lot of times this depends
on The annotation so for example when
you upload your metadata you can have
multiple types of annotation sample name
for example here we have control and
psoriasis
and here we have control and psoriasis
but we can change this if we had
kind of other types of information
we could definitely look at that now
some of this information is not very
useful let's take a look at a different
example this different example is going
to be
with a little bit more metadata so here
you can see a much clearer example this
is a comparison between BV and normal
but you have quite a number of different
types of
phenotypes added to the table so this is
specifically vaginal microbiome now it's
very clear right you can see right here
lactobacilla so we can find it right
here
and you can see that it is much more
prevalent for normal and less abundant
for BV
now here we can also change what exactly
are we looking for for example just
agent gestational age or we can look for
example by race
so here we're looking by race there's
black and white
and I don't know if we necessarily
expect there to be a lot of variation
but we can certainly check
and there could be some variation
so we can identify manually some of them
for example you can see all of these
they're not very consistent across this
group but they're definitely more
present for white women rather than
black
now you can do the same thing over here
you can for example this is term and
preterm birth and you have phenotype you
have disease right here
we can change this to disease as well so
you can definitely play around with the
data and kind of understand Global
differences individual differences at
different levels of taxonomy and also
Alpha diversity plots here where by race
Let's Take a Look by phenotype we have
term versus preterm birth and we also
have disease so we see BV versus normal
this seems to be
less number of
otus in this group
so this dashboard can give you insights
and can give you some ideas on how to
perform Downstream analysis down here
you will find the actual table you can
download it and Export it by the
different level of taxonomy as well and
if there's an image that you would like
to save for example you you saw
that maybe
um
maybe this is a group or this is a taxa
that you want to highlight you can
download either you can open the HTML
or an SVG and and so that will download
a figure that you can then open up
uh and you can see right here
we can preview or you can even open it
in Adobe Illustrator to edit it
and you can see that this is something
that is easy to work with and you kind
of have all of The annotation right here
or you can also download this as an HTML
and that HTML is something that you can
now open a bigger view of the same
figure
and and that can help you kind of you
know make it
um more
you know stretch it and kind of save it
the way that you would like over here
you can actually now create a PNG
and that's a plotly function
so this would be a pretty high quality
figure that you can include in your
presentation